2021 is just around the corner a lot of
people already making goals for the new
year including
financial goals to talk about some
attainable
goals for the new year we're joined by
micah phillips of nevada state bank
micah thanks so much
for joining us today glad to be here
kendall thanks for having me you have
some great ideas some tips on how to
do some simple things that are small
incremental steps that can make a big
difference
absolutely you know in the new year
people are often resetting around
fitness goals and savings goals
and uh we've all seen the jibs fill up
in january and be empty
two weeks later the same thing is true
with financial goals it's about setting
realistic goals
and making it a part of your everyday
life in a way that's manageable so for
example
um you know setting up an automatic
transfer or putting a reminder in your
phone to set aside some money
start little and make it reasonable and
keep it top of mind
obviously what can people do if you know
and this is unfortunately the case for a
lot of people right now if they don't
have
income if maybe they're in between jobs
or
they've been temporarily laid off
because of everything going on
yeah 2020 has certainly been an
interesting year and for anyone that's
facing
an income situation that is a little bit
irregular
it might be about setting a monthly goal
or a monthly target that they try to
work toward
through the different bits of income
they may be receiving
or maybe it's even setting aside a
little bit of cash maybe you take those
one dollar bills
and you stash those to the side as a way
to try to put something there
uh for the rainy day yeah michael what i
like about your goals is you constantly
stress that they be
attainable and realistic so what can
people do
to make their goals to make sure that
their goals are realistic
right you know sometimes savings can be
overwhelming for people because they
think about this is what i should be
doing
and it feels big and unachievable
but if they focus on what's reasonable
for me
and i start little you know i think
about my own situation when my kids were
young
i wanted to put away some college
savings for them and
uh you know that was overwhelming i
started out putting
five dollars a month in an account for
them and at the time it felt like it was
maybe even pointless
but in time that money really
accumulated and it mattered and so
it's about figuring out what little
incremental step can you take
and then when you have wins and
successes
figure out what the next goal is and set
another goal right and
and keep moving toward it and in time
it's amazing how it can
change the outlook on on savings and
make a big difference
in the year to come micah thank you so
much for joining us great tips
really appreciate it thanks kendall we
want to thank nevada state bank for
being one of our community pride
partners